bonsoir nous sommes le lundi 26 octobre
merci de nous retrouver pour cette
nouvelle édition du 7 8 le journal on
commence tout de suite avec les titres
de votre actualité locale
manuel valls et 17 de ses ministres
étaient aux mureaux ce matin dans les
yvelines pour une réunion du comité
égalité et citoyenneté
lancée au lendemain des émeutes de 2005
en banlieue ce comité doit répondre au
problème de mixité sociale
plusieurs mesures annoncées le point
dans quelques instants politique
toujours mais du côté de la campagne des
régionales europe écologie les verts
vient de réunir ses candidats dans le
département pour une présentation du
programme europe ecologie les verts qui
restent très critiques envers l'action
de ses anciens alliés socialistes
et puis invité ce soir à bernard
delattre ancien journaliste devenu
auteur il vient de publier vies
tranchées
récit d'une sélection de faits divers
qui l'a couvert durant toute sa carrière
nous on parlera dans quelques instants
et nouvelle édition de la transat
jacques vabre quarante deux voiliers
engagés dans la compétition depuis
dimanche en direction du brésil parmi
les skippers le versailles et tanguy de
lamotte c'est sa quatrième participation
et ce rendez-vous lui permettra de se
préparer pour le prochain vendée globe
il est toujours sous les couleurs
d'initiative coeur soutenu par mécénat
chirurgie cardiaque afin de permettre
d'opérer des enfants atteints de graves
maladies cardiaques et provenant de pays
défavorisés
écoutez le juste avant le départ au
havre il était au micro de grégory canal
pour radio sensations ce week-end donc
c'est l'opération qu'on a commencé avec
mon sponsor initiatives pour le vendée
globe dont qu'on a appelé le bateau
initiative coeur l'histoire que ce soit
simple de comprendre qu' on essaie
d'aider des enfants qui ont des
problèmes cardiaques et donc c'est
simple on a une page facebook qui
s'appelle initiative coeur quand vous
venez cliquer dessus
quand vous liker la page pour la
première fois quand vous aimez la page
pour la première fois à chaque fois à
chaque nouveau nouvelles personnes mon
sponsor donne 2 euros à l'association et
à chaque fois que vous partagez les
postes qu'on peut mettre sur le facebook
mon sponsor donne un euro à
l'association donc là depuis qu'on est
au havre on a pu
depuis c'est le début de la semaine on a
pu sauver déjà quatre ou cinq enfants
je crois qu'on est déjà au 5e ce soir
est donc c'est notre objectif la danse
au v10 pour la transat donc vu le départ
que le bon départ qu'on a pris alors que
la course n'est même pas encore parti on
a pu sauver déjà cinq enfants ça coûte
rien aux internautes il faut juste venir
cliquer sur la page facebook et grâce à
vous mes sponsors de donne des sous à
l'association est grâce à vous des
petits enfants sont sauvés déplacements
ministériels dans les yvelines dix ans
après les émeutes urbaines qui ont
embrasé la france en 2005
manuel valls s'est rendu ce matin aux
mureaux dans le cadre du deuxième comité
interministériel à l'égalité et à la
citoyenneté
le chef du gouvernement accompagné de
dix être ministre a d'abord participé à
une visite de terrain du nouveau
commissariat de la mission locale avant
de sa brassée de s'adresser à la presse
pour annoncer de nouvelles mesures
viennent elles étaient sur place ce sont
cinq nouvelles mesures qui viennent
désormais s'ajouter aux 60 annoncé en
mars dernier lors du comité
interministériel à l'égalité et à la
citoyenneté
lors de sa conférence de presse aux
mureaux ce matin le premier ministre a
fait savoir la volonté du gouvernement
de reconnaître les obstacles auxquels
sont confrontés les habitants des
quartiers défavorisés les obstacles de
plusieurs natures
je les dis difficulté sociale qui
persiste discrimination
parfois ça s'appelle tout simplement du
racisme qui font des dégâts
considérables sur les destins
individuels scolaire professionnel
stigmatisation à l'endroit de l'islam
alors que la deuxième religion de france
cherche sa place dans notre société
parmi ces cinq nouvelles mesures pour
revaloriser ces quartiers faciliter les
relations entre les forces de l'ordre et
la population prévenir la radicalisation
et lutter contre les discriminations
beaucoup en parler emploi accès à
l'emploi créé son entreprise
l'accompagnement culture bref tous les
sujets sont abordés pour qui une action
publique globale qui fasse que voilà on
salue les quartiers comme une chance
c'est une chance dans ces mesures
également lutter contre la ségrégation
notamment dans le logement et la
construction d'habitat social ou 36
villes sont déjà pointés du doigt comme
la commune de maisons laffitte dans les
yvelines renforcer les sanctions contre
les nerfs refusant de construire des
logements sociaux en transférant ou
préfet le contingent municipal
d'attribution il faut que les choses
bougent et l'état emploi et emploiera
tous les moyens nécessaires
il prendra la main s'il le faut comme la
loi l'y autorise la dernière mesure
s'inscrirait dans la continuité du
contrat de ville mise en oeuvre pour
rénover l'action publique dans les
quartiers et la rendre plus cohérente et
efficace annoncé ce matin la nomination
de délégués du gouvernement dans les
villes pour coordonner l'action des
services de l'état et ses opérations en
lien avec le préfet et le maire dix
sites pilotes ont déjà été choisies pour
cette mesure avec notamment la commune
de trappes dans les yvelines et
politiques toujours à plus d'un mois des
élections régionales les partis
commencent après les parties commencent
à présenter leur liste et leurs
programmes
europe ecologie les verts ont mené par
emmanuelle cosse la tête de liste front
signe elle présentait ses candidats
samedi dernier avant que la ville
explications avec mélanie potier mois
des moines changer l'air de l'île de
france c'est le moderne d'europe
écologie les verts
point principal de leur programme un
plan outre la pollution 3 milliards
d'euros seraient ainsi consacré aux
déplacements qui a un lien très concret
entre les enjeux de cette élection
régionale et les enjeux climat notre
région et tous nos continuerons à
développer les transports par route de
bus et nous porterons un projet de
liaison par lé transport en commun par
le train des banlieues à banlieues en
tant qu'habitant de la grande banlieue
je n'ai plus envie de continuer
systématiquement à repasser par paris
pour aller dans une autre banlieue mi
octobre le parti socialiste avait
organisé un référendum pour envisager
une alliance avec les écologistes
si le oui l'a emporté à 89% du côté des
verts l'alliance pour le premier tour
n'est pas d'actualité référendum
j'aurais plutôt dit micro trottoir vous
aviez imaginé où ils en sont ils sont
allés sur les marchés demandé aux
citoyens de trancher des questions
d'alliances entre les appareils
notre campagne ne s'inscrit pas là
dedans j'invite mes collègues du parti
socialiste avec lesquelles nous avons
été en partenariat après avoir été
autonome en 2010 de faire campagne de
faire connaître leurs projets et de
parler à leurs électeurs sur la liste
emmenée par emmanuelle cosse une dizaine
de candidats sont yvelinois pour le
département les candidats se disent être
attentif à la préservation des terres
agricoles notamment sur le plateau de
saclay lors des régionales de 2010 la
liste écologiste avait obtenu 16% des
suffrages au premier tour
90 migrants sont arrivés vendredi
dernier à triel-sur-seine évacuer ce
vendredi matin du lycée désaffecté jean
charest à paris
ils ont été installés dans l'ancienne
maison de retraite des tilleuls
principalement des hommes pour la
plupart originaires du soudan ils sont
encadrés sur place par les représentants
de la croix rouge française
trente-cinq personnes de l'association
ont été mobilisés 24 heures sur 24 sur
le site pour leur apporter de l'aide
les migrants pourrait rester jusqu'à la
fin mars 2016 le temps de l'examen de
leur situation par les services de
l'état
d'autres migrants évacués vendredi matin
également de paris ont été dirigés vers
d'autres communes des yvelines
un groupe a notamment été accueilli à
elancourt et un autre au foyer adoma de
conflans sainte honorine et nous
accueillons ce soir bernard delattre son
bonsoir vous êtes journaliste et
écrivain une figure bien connue
adhérents bolide teint et vous venez
nous parler de votre recueil qui
s'intitule vies tranchées
alors ce n'est pas un polar ce n'est pas
un treillis un thriller mais ça un
recueil de 16 nouvelles inspirées de
faits divers qui se sont déroulés en
bourgogne dans les yvelines également à
paris et qu'ils vous ont marqué devant
votre cas de journalistes
oui tout à fait et oui c'est vraiment
des choses qui m'ont marqué quoi qu'il
me voir traumatisé tellement cette des
choses graves depuis donc le but
principal de ce livre c'est de collecter
des fonds pour l'association lumière du
monde qui réalisent des puits d'eau
potable au cameroun
donc j'avais déjà fait deux
deux autres livres dans cette opération
un livre sur la musique des années 60 le
rock le funk
vous avez écrit déjà vivre alors
j'aimerais qu'on revienne sur ce livre a
précisément donc qu'il amène donc via
tranché comment vous avez choisi
justement ce sont des choses qui vous
ont marqués qui ont aussi remarqué
peut-être les yvelinois les vosgiens
juge je pense oui ce sont des choses qui
ont marqué tout le monde comme quelque
chose pour nous en parler quelques
exemples de ce qui m'a le plus marqué
c'est la tragédie la de l'avion
militaire le mystère 20 qui s'écrasé le
2 décembre 1991 donc il ya 24 ans à
elancourt maurepas dans la coulée verte
et nous il se trouvait qu'on avait un
reportage amour pas avec le maire de
maurepas de l'époque puis on a
pratiquement vu l'avion tomber on arrive
en même temps qu'ils sapeurs pompiers
normalement il faut là j'ai voulu ça m'a
inspiré une nouvelle pour un dommage à
ses officiers de l'armée de l'air qui
avaient tous des meilleurs des milliers
d'heures d'expérience qui sont sacrifiés
pour qu'ils ont pris tous les risques
pour eux pour éviter les immeubles qui a
veillé des zones d'immeubles dans le
koala les 7 marc l'agio tout ça donc
c'est un moment de leur rendre hommage
et les autres nouvelles donc c'est des
affaires qui montrait marqué une affaire
d'infanticide qui dote aussi d'une
trentaine d'années nous allons tourner
la ville nouvelle et c'était une mère de
famille traders épicerie trader est
dépressive qui a noyé ses enfants et qui
a loupé son suicide derrière c'est
beaucoup de bruit puis en même temps si
on s'aperçoit que donc le phénomène
l'infanticide sait que c'est un des
drames qui le nombre augmente
malheureusement en france chaque année
donc c'est pas nouveau parce que dans le
théâtre antique vous avez la pièce mais
des par exemple la tragédie médée
d'euripide qui date de quatre siècles
avant jésus-christ qui décrit justement
ce phénomène de la france ici d'affamés
des est un peu le mythe de tout cela et
on voit que ça revient toujours
j'ai voulu à peut savoir ce qui a pu se
passer dans la tête des gens comment
vous inspire le fait 10
mais vous le raconter sous forme d'oeuf
c'est ça oui de forme de fiction c'est
ça ouais c'est pour la compassion je
pense aussi par l'éditeur
l'identification l'identification
ça appartient aux processus de
compassion puisse en même temps pour
protéger les familles quoi on va pas
remettre les noms des lieux précis puis
en même temps donc c'est pour imaginer
les dialogues je suis pas sur des
dialogues donc si ce sont vraiment des
nouvelles de fiction c'est la fiction
la trame de ce sont des faits divers
réels mais tout le les dialogues sur la
fiction même parfois le dénuement et de
la fiction parce que moi j'étais simple
journaliste on va vous le savez un
journaliste ne juge ni juge ni policier
on sait pas tout évidemment ce n'était
pas trop de vin parce que en tant que
juriste vous déviez vraiment fait il a
passé sa voix j'ai recommencé way puis
c'est vrai que par des enquêtes de
voisinage avait certaines choses que
j'avais pas pu maintenant dans les
articles mais là bon j'ai pu y aller
c'est vraiment de la fiction de nous
avait vraiment inquiété sur toutes les
affaires dont vous les montre oui mais
pas tous pas toujours tous les éléments
quoi je connais que certains aspects
donc je me suis basé sur ce que je
savais alors qu'il avait 27 ans et une
fois qu'il reste à peut-être un complexe
d serait donnée il ya des cas où les
libr trier court toujours
g leca parrain ii de maçon portugais du
sud des yvelines il était à un an de la
retraite et il ya un jour ils sont
partis sur un chantier personne ne les a
jamais revus
alors la loi française est tellement est
fait de façon que ceux ci on retrouve
pas les cadavres il n'y a pas de crime
et là on n'a jamais retrouvé les corps
on mais c'étaient des dégâts très
sérieux qui bossent ceux qui bossaient
qui envoyait tout leur argent à leur
famille ils ont disparu à laurier il ya
deux hypothèses soit ce leur employeur
parce qu'ils avaient un procès de aux
prud'hommes justement pour les impayés
deux heures supplémentaires de dimanche
l'ours est une piste mais sur le terrain
j'ai appris une autre piste aussi parce
que pied en plus on ne peut pas accuser
tant que c'est pas jugée et il ya aussi
une autre piste sur le terrain on m'a
dit que ces gars là il aurait peut-être
bosser pour nous c'est qu'en forêt de
rambouillet ya des fois des gens qui se
cachent alors ça peut être soit des
filières terroristes ou des des grands
malfrats et il aurait peut-être
travailler pour ces gens là des
souterrains ou des choses comme ça et on
leur aurait éliminé pour qu'ils parlent
pas donc à ces deux hypothèses
je vais continuer à vos enquêtes
justement pour écrire ces nouvelles j'ai
pas les moyens j'ai aucun moyen j'ai
jugé bon mais ça c'est sûr les faits
divers il s'étale sur 40 ans de carrière
les écrire bon me sera pris sur 6 mois 1
an puis avec l'éditrice à la maison
d'ici on a beaucoup travaillé les
dialogues la maison d'édition flamande
voir nous nous y reviendrons vous avez
écrit d'autres livres avant là c'était
vraiment un recueil c'était un peu calé
voulait pas peut-être faire passer un
message
oui c'est faire un peu un tour d'horizon
parce que les faits divers sont comme un
reflet de la société a montré un peu par
la mère de famille dépressif pas
sous-estimer la dépression mais aussi
deux affaires qui vont marquer cd des
jeunes un est mort et l'autre a failli
mourir pour avoir voulu acheter acheter
un peu de shit
je trouve ça c'est vraiment alors s'il
pourrait bien expliquer aux jeunes et
aux familles attention y'a plus
dangereux que le shit c'est le contact
et que les dealers parce que là vous
avez des sensations prévention que c'est
ça mais il ya attention les dealers là
vous avez vraiment des crapules des gens
qui n'ont pas de drogue et qui ont des
couteaux vous avez donc une carrière de
40 ans de journalistes notamment donc
sur le territoire de rambouillet est ce
que je sais pas c'est peut-être un
territoire où il ya beaucoup de
d'affaires de deux faits divers comme
celles ci ont eu lieu n'ont pas plus
qu'ailleurs non il n'a pas pu écrire
puis ce qui s'est passé ici dans le sud
yvelines
on est très bien puisse passer à nantes
à bordeaux
marseille voila c c'est simple on est
dans l'humain en général j'ai voulu un
peu exploré dans l'âme humaine quoi il
ya un auteur j'aime bien la frédérick
tristan qui a été prix goncourt en 1983
avec les égards et un très beau roman
sur la folie humaine
il habite d'ailleurs pas très loin d'ici
mais il a écrit la descente dans les
ténèbres de la folie mais le prélude
nécessaires à la remontée vers la
lumière
donc parfois faut descendre dans les
ténèbres pour remonter vers la lumière
alors j'espère que ces nouvelles on
descend dans les ténèbres
ça va aider les gens à remonter leurs la
mineure en tant que jeunesse nous savons
les faits divers intéresse beaucoup le
public les lecteurs c'est comme des
histoires assez tragique assez assez
dure est-ce que vraiment il ya des
choses qu'on peut en retirer
oui c'est ça la clé du voyeurisme pascal
bats un aspect mais il ya peut-être une
overdose de faits divers actuellement
une autre tel trop il ya trop de
violence et justement on a là des
processus d'augmentation de la volonté
il faut étudier ça je pense justement
pour contrer pourquoi il ya tous ces
phénomènes mais comment on peut les
contrer c'est ça faut étudier ce sont
des défaites société aussi par mail à
l'est la dépression il faut bien
diagnostic dépression une maladie très
grave et tous les diagnostics et à temps
pour éviter les tragédies parisot alors
donc vous sortez à ce livre aux éditions
du flamand noir donc cette maison a été
fondée il ya deux ans par mata nathalie
brook qui est spécialisé dans le roman
policier le thriller c'est une mission
une maison d'édition health yvelinoise
sentiment un livre 100% yvelinois wheels
est une jeune maison d'édition de
kit qui a deux ans à peine elle va fêter
son deuxième anniversaire et j'ai voulu
travailler avec eux parce que j'aime
bien comme ça lance est une maison
d'édition actuellement faut du courage
vous faut du cran ce que le milieu du
livre est un peu saturé la rose et lancé
une maison d'édition et chapeau 1
mais là donc en deux ans madame nathalie
broux elle a déjà obtenu deux prix un
prix avec kind of black c'est un polar
qui se déroule dans les milieux du jazz
et en même temps sa romance sur la
création musicale le piano tout ça mais
le deuxième c'est burn-out là qui va
avoir un prix aussi on peut pas trop le
dire parce que il va être décernée
bientôt dans un prochain salon et c'est
un peu sur la déprime des policiers vous
savez aussi que le nombre des suicides
dépenses et augmenter et voilà le burn
out et là il décrit parfaitement c'est
un ancien policier
didier fossé il décrit parfaitement
cette ambiance dans les commissariats
les gens surmené dui long larmes avec
eux quoi et comment vous avez travaillé
justement a donc accepté la mission
oui c'est sûr mais on a beaucoup
travaillé les dialogues parlés repris le
dialogue elle m'a dit mme claes
il faudra un peu élaguer là bien au
contraire enrichir chercher la médaille
la touche féminine quoi il était un des
clubs donc pour ce livre vos droits
d'auteur seront reversés pour la
réalisation de puits d'eau potable au
cameroun avec l'associé l'association
rambo liten bénévoles lumière du monde
qui est présidente présidée par madame
virginie simo vous investissez beaucoup
pour cette association
oui mais j'y suis depuis plus de dix ans
à l'association veut fêter son quinzième
anniversaire en mars 2016 et moi je suis
pratiquement depuis le début parce que
je bouge j'ai beaucoup d'affection pour
faire des puits d'eau potable aussi des
latrines un peu aidé à créer des projets
relancer alors c'est parti d'une famille
camerounaise à madame simone cap sipa
elle a voulu aider son son village
d'origine et son village quand on dit
village c'est ça va de 10000 à 20000
habitants
donc on a déjà fait deux 2 actions dans
des villages de
bong fokam et le nom est là le prochain
c'est bayangam médaille en gamme ses
près de 20000 habitants donc par là bang
bang focale on a fait c'est ce puits
d'eau potable 12 latrines des deux
lettres dans les écoles aussi donc c'est
vraiment un travail de fond sur toute
une communauté urbaine et on travaille
avec des gens du coin les puits sont
faits par une entreprise de yaoundé et
c'est pas de l'assistanat on
responsabilise les gens parce que après
les gens payent un euro par mois pour
l'entretien du puits à 1 euro c'est 900
francs cfa donc c'est quelque chose
d'assez énorme et donc ceux qui
financent entretien des puits tout ça
quoi donc voilà c'est pour une bonne
cause s'il ya vraiment je sais pas
peut-être une nouvelle un récit que vous
pourriez vous nous conseillez a vraiment
eu vous a le plus touché laquelle ce
serait dans ce bel hommage aux aviateurs
que le sacrifice de ces pilotes qui ont
évité les mais les immeubles et les
maisons ont pris tous les risques pour
eux quoi voilà il ya une stèle a été
inaugurée à locaux le côté de la
commanderie des templiers
chaque fois je passe devant je m'arrête
quoi respect pour ces gens
mais l'an prochain donc en décembre 2016
ça va être le 25e anniversaire d'accord
alors je le rappelle votre livre vies
tranchées est disponible dans les
librairies de la ville nouvelle ainsi
que sur internet et vous lui dédicacerai
le dimanche 8 novembre au samedi des
écrivains de rambouillet merci beaucoup
bernard delattre d'être venu en plateau
et que nous avoir parlé justement de
votre livre culture maintenant on y
reste justement il ya tout juste trois
cents ans s'éteignent et le roi soleil à
l'occasion de cet anniversaire
le château de versailles retrace le
cérémonial qui entourait la mort de
louis xiv vous pourrez ainsi découvrir
les derniers instants du roi mais aussi
les étapes d'exposition du corps du
défunt et le convoi funèbre des moments
de représentation mis en lumière par une
scénographie baroque
l'exposition est à découvrir au château
jusqu'au 21 février 2016 on écoute tout
de suite la commissaire de l'exposition
béatrix saule cette exposition accorde à
la scénographie une place toute
particulière parce que elle est tout à
fait dans l'esprit de ce que c'était car
toute la cérémonie les est un motif
funèbre de louis xiv ont été organisées
par l'administration des menus plaisirs
et c'était des décors éphémères des
costumes éphémère tout était fait pour
la cérémonie pour ce temps de deuil
et comme chaque lundi nous retrouvons
notre chronique culturelle a présenté
par sephora namani bonsoir sephora
bonsoir floene alors ce soir je vous
parle le cinéma s'est vu comment on fait
un film alors j'ai quelques nations mais
pas suffisamment mais vous allez
certainement me dire où l'on peut
apprendre en faire un jeu suppose
exactement alors c'était tout l'objet en
fait du stage qui se déroulait à
guyancourt pendant les vacances
scolaires à la villa simone signoret
pour les adolescents de 11 à 17 ans une
dizaine de jeunes ont bénéficié des
conseils d'une équipe de professionnels
pour réaliser leur premier court métrage
alors un court métrage ce n'est pas
vraiment un film simple course sympa un
mini film c'est ça alors officiellement
court métrage c'est 50 c'est moins de 52
minutes mais conventionnellement du même
qu'un court métrage c'est moins de 26
minutes
en l'occurrence là leur premier court
métrage fera de 5 à 10 minutes c'est
thomas hardy responsable de du service
jeunesse de la ville de guyancourt qui
nous précise le programme lapointe chose
c'est qu'est ce que c'est que le cinéma
comment ça fonctionne quels sont les
différents plans de vue est donc
maintenant ils les connaissent sur le
bout des doigts et c'est assez
impressionnant ensuite quels sont les
matériels nécessaires pour faire le
tournage d'un film
ensuite une fois qu'on a appréhendé un
peu tous ces outils là on commence à
écrire le scénario
on commence à avoir des idées plus
précises dans la mise en scène et puis
on commença à créer à mettre le puzzle
commence à prendre forme dans toutes ses
étapes progressives
alors ils sont donc initier aux
différentes étapes de la création d'un
film depuis l'écriture du synopsis
jusqu'au montage en passant par le
scénario le storyboard et le tournage
lors quelque petit rappel le synopsis
dans l'industrie cinématographique et
désigne le résumé condensé d'un scénario
et le storybox et la représentation
illustré d'un film avant sa réalisation
la mise en page ressemble à celle d'une
bande dessinée et au fait ça sert à
planifier l'ensemble des plans avant la
réalisation du film on y précise
l'ensemble des paramètres
cinématographiques tels que le cadrage
des mouvements de caméra et de
personnages et les raccords avec la plus
grande exactitude possible afin de visu
alizée et de planifier le tournage du
film on a même eu droit un petit cours
sur les différents plans on va faire
deux échelles de plans c'est quoi les
échelles de plans déjà est pas mal mais
c'est bien d'avoir essayé non non je
voulais pas je voulais sincère alors je
le précise dans l extrait le plan qui
arrive bien jusqu'aux genoux c'est le
plan italien de lui parce que je sais
qu'on entend un petit peu moins bien
alors pour les non-initiés un plan c'est
une prise de vue de quelques secondes
mais qui peut durer aussi jusqu'à
plusieurs minutes c'est ça exactement
alors pour simplifier le plan c'est le
jeu de scène filmée entre les deux mots
magiques du tournage qui son action est
coupée et un ensemble de plans situé
dans un même temps et dans le même lieu
forme une séquence est un ensemble de
ces camps se rapportant à une même
action mais se déroulant en différents
lieux et sur différentes en donner forme
ce que l'on appelle une scène
alors je vous donne toutes les clés
folle florane pour créer un film un jour
s'il envie vous à d'être on espère alors
la technique n'a pas été laissée pour
compte ou non plus parce que nos jeunes
ont pu s'essayer au métier de caméraman
éclairagiste preneur de son ainsi qu'un
l'actorat l'actorat c'est le nouveau mot
pour parler du métier de comédien
c'était donc un bilan positif pour ce
stage à mi parcours parce que tous les
enfants se sont prêtés au jeu avec
sérieux et enrichie de nouvelles
connaissances techniques
on les écoute chacun on touche un peu à
tout moi j'ai décidé de participer
au journal télévisé qu'on va faire et et
mais je préfère quand même faire plus de
technique de être cameraman ou prends
200 moi j'aime bien la réalisation être
derrière les caméras ça me plaît bien ça
pouvait me permettre de vendre à ce
qu'il y avait dans le monde du cinéma et
puis comme on m'a dit c'était assez
professionnel voulait comme sur un
troisième est que j'ai un stage à faire
et bien il fallait savoir comment
c'était dans le monde professionnel
parce que j'avais déjà fait un stage au
cinéma mais si tu es plus amateur est là
avec une équipe de pros ça me permet de
vraiment d'apprendre ce métier alors ce
stage initié par le service jeunesse de
la ville de guyancourt se prolonge
jusqu'à la fin des vacances scolaires
l'expérience se terminera par la
projection du court métrage réalisé par
les stagiaires lors d'une soirée de
clôture vendredi prochain peut-être des
futurs sofia coppola luc besson c'est ce
qu'on verra sephora merci en tout cas on
vous retrouve mercredi pour une nouvelle
édition de kiosques mais avant de
refermer cette édition un mot de sport
lourde défaite pour montigny le
bretonneux en nationale 1 féminine de
handball les imitaient ni perdu 32 à 24
à domicile face à rochechouart lors de
la 5e journée de championnat les
saint-quentinoises concèdent donc leur
deuxième défaite consécutive
résumé du match avec mickael miro et
elodie moines deuxième défaite en deux
matches de national
une pour montigny-le-bretonneux privé de
quelques cadres lésigny montrent elles
n'ont jamais réussi à contenir les
assauts de rochechouart l'une des
meilleures équipes de la coudre dans
leur jeu
naze le score est sans appel 32 à 24 on
n'était pas loin on revient et puis
après on relâche sur les dernières
minutes on fait des erreurs qu'on
devrait pas faire et donc ça coûte cher
sur des équipes du vidéo tableau on a eu
un départ de match difficile ce qui nous
a mis dedans
presque tout le match bon on en a su
relever la tête à densifier notre
défense qui nous a permis à près de
récupérer des balles et puis les années
jusqu en attaque mais oui il ya un écart
c'est sûr mais pas tant que ça je pense
pas pas tant que ça on est loin parce
qu'il ya moins 8 à la fin mai
il faut retenir les bonnes choses et à
son jeu ont su relever la tête et ça
c'est ça c'est bien pour l'avenir
promu cette année en nationale une
montille retenues visent le maintien
cette saison
après un départ en boulet de canon avec
deux victoires en trois matchs les ig
monteyne marque le pas depuis début
octobre et illinoise reste sur trois
défaites consécutives toutes
compétitions confondues
on va y arriver on travaille beaucoup la
semaine
après je pense qu'il faut vraiment me
garder positif sur chaque match même
s'il va y avoir but sans doute beaucoup
de défaites et je pense qu'on va y
arriver il faut rester bien régulière
pour rêver du maintien il faudra
engranger le plus de points possible
prochain match nationale une pour
montigny-le-bretonneux samedi prochain à
20h contre pessac et en gironde et c'est
la fin de cette édition tout de suite
vous avez rendez vous avec michael elle
me d'euros pour le 7-8 sport je vous
retrouve demain et je vous souhaite une
très bonne soirée